today's pointers from a pediatrician
segment is focused on
getting our kids ready for the return to
school dr kerry weejay singha the owner
and medical director of siena pediatrics
joins us once again
and dr kerry this is very timely august
is national immunization awareness month
so let's go over what the required
vaccinations are for kindergartners
followed by seventh graders
hi how are you guys thank you um okay
it's back to school time
and we've been very busy taking care of
all the kids the teenagers too
getting their shots up to date so i'd
just like to probably
kind of summarize it that there's eight
different kinds of vaccines a
kindergartner needs
to have and basically i'll round this
off it's a lot to process but there's
five diphtheria tetanus pertussis
vaccines you need
before you enter kindergarten there
needs to be four prevnar vaccines and
three to four hip vaccines that's
meningitis ones like categorized
and then you need kind of hepatitises
there's three hepatitis b's and
two hepas um lastly you know the mmrs
and the
box you need two of those as well
and that's the required i know that
sounds a lot but that's the required
vaccines that you need to have
before you get into kindergarten the
seventh graders they need
um before they enter seventh grade is
they need a meningitis
one and a tdap and uh so those are the
ones that are the most common that you
have to get
i still recommend you the teens getting
gardasil
and then something called the meningitis
the ones okay
and yeah parents it gets better i mean i
remember before kindergarten
mia was oh my gosh in tears she tried to
run away from us as we were giving her
all those shots
but you know it gets better over the
years parents it gets a lot easier
dr kerry what are some of the common
side effects from these routine vaccines
so the most common is is that obviously
a low-grade fever
uh soreness at the site of the injection
and the little babies can be fussy uh
too as well
um some specific ones mmr can cause a
ration of fever a week later as well
and the pediatrician should be able to
guide you and talk to you about that
at the weld checks too wonderful and an
important question can you get the covet
vaccine
if you're above 12 and the routine
vaccines at the same time dr kerry
yes you can so this past summer the uh
cdc
pretty much said that you can get it on
the same day any vaccine that we
normally give and the covid and i've had
several patients doing the same already
all right a very very busy time thank
you so much for your time today
dr kerry weejay singha we appreciate it
we'll check back with you in a few weeks
here
and we hope all is well with you thank
you take care youtube
thanks so much dr carey